Madeline is with us in Montgomery
Alabama hi Madeline how are you I'm fine
how are you better than I deserve what's
up know me also I had a question about
second marriage finances and it's been a
kind of a heartache from me my husband I
have been married just a few years and
everything's separate and nothing
together um he doesn't believe in
combining and that anything that he had
before he married me it's going to be
mine mm-hmm so there's a lot of mine and
yours but I know you talked about one
time about our pronouns and how
important it is toward the oneness and I
feel like we just don't have that yeah
you don't and it's probably because
probably because he got taken to the
cleaners in the first one did he get
taken to the cleaners in the first one
yeah yeah so are you paying for the sins
of the first wife he's judging you based
on that and that's totally wrong that
means he is not fully healed from his
first divorce and so were he one of my
buddies I'd put my arm around him and
pop him on top of the noggin because
he's you know he's exactly like that his
new wife is his roommate in the old
marriage vows it comes out and it used
to say back in the day for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
which means I want you and oneness and
unity with you more than I want stuff
and he's got his little marbles over
here in the corner and he's guarding
them like you're coming to get them
that's ridiculous absolutely ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous but it's but I
understand I mean he got really got the
snot beat out of him the first go-round
but he needs to address those wounds
because it is unfair it's it's affecting
your all's relationship because it
leaves you out in the cold it leaves you
feeling very separated from your husband
you do not have the level of unity that
you should have and this is a marriage
issue it's not a financial issue but
it's showing up in the marriage issue in
other words he's holding back because
he's scared mm-hmm
he's still scared and you know I would
challenge him to get to the bottom of
that for his sake and for the sake of
his marriage because of the way it's
leaving you feeling right yeah and I
suggested counseling but he he he will
not he will not agree to that so that's
a problem you know hey I got a problem
with you you're a jerk I'm gonna go to
counseling and talk about you if you're
not gonna go that's what I'm gonna do I
mean this is a problem this guy this
guy's guy this guy's got a lot of stuff
going on and you know you guys need some
coaching through this I don't see this
ending well if you guys don't deal with
this because you're getting
progressively over this discussion and
truthfully you should be I don't why I'm
not calling for you to end something I'm
not calling for any of that but it would
be to his great benefit to learn to get
on the same page with his wife and not
hold his former marriage against his
current wife and if you like your stuff
more than you like her boys and girls
you should not marry her that's why with
very rare exceptions I tell people not
to get a prenup the one lady calling and
said her boyfriend has a classic car and
he wants a prenup to protect her from
the getting the car in the event of a
divorce
he loves his car more than he loves you
honey don't marry him that was my answer
what a twerp you have to have a prenup
for your freaking car
seriously and and you know that that's
the same kind of spirit as to what we're
dealing with here
and so you know unless you've got like a
bazillion dollars like millions and
millions and millions of dollars and the
other party doesn't in the extreme
situation a prenup is in order because
it actually does clean up things
relationally then and it takes away all
the it's really not even the person
you're married that you're worried about
it's a crazy freaking family that's what
you're worried about in those situations
where there's an extreme differential
differential but you know in a situation
where you're coming into a second
marriage this is why pre-marriage
counseling is absolutely vital so that
you can agree that we have put all of
those damaged relationships and broken
hearts in the past and these scars are
not going to be carried forward into
this marriage and we are going to set
this up fresh clean new and precious and
we're gonna set it up where we are just
like two 18 year old kids getting
married and we didn't know any better
we're going to just combine everything
and if you're not willing to do that
that should be an indication to you
you've not yet recovered from your
formal relationship break up and you're
not working yet ready to be married
see a good marriage counselor and see if
they don't tell you the same thing
that's what we run into all the time and
that's what Madeline is running into so
yes Madeline you all need marriage
counseling darling I hope you can get it